من داخلي هذه القاعه واختتمت فعاليات
الملتقى التحضيري لمؤتمر المصالحه الوطنيه
اتفاق جميع الاطراف على وحده ليبيا وضماني
سيادتها ايضا اتفق الحاضرون هنا على اقامه
المؤتمر الجامع خلال شهرين داخل ليبيا
فيما استمر الخلافه على العالم والنشيد
[تصفيق]
خمسه ايام لم يكن سهلا في الخلافات
والمشدات الكلاميه كانت حاضره حتى الدقائق
الاخيره من الاجتماع
جلسات اليوم الاول بسبب العالم والنشيد
والسنه المشروط لن ينجح اذا كان صلح من
اجل الوطن وبدومات نحن مرحبتين اذا كان
صلح الان في مساومات او بعوده شخصيات
سابقه او
اسقاط العالم ولا النشيد بدون دستور بدون
احنا في حلمنا ويعتبر الفعل
الى مرحله المؤتمر الجامع الذي سيعقد في
مدينه معايده يتفق عليها الجميع
العلم والنشيد هو محل نزاع دستوري وما دام
العلم والنشيد تنص عليه الماده 3 في
الاعلان الدستوري المؤقت وهو الان دستور
المؤقت المؤقت الى ان نتفق على دستور ترحل
هذه الماده الى القاعده الشعبيه
من اجل انجاح ملف المصالحه الوطنيه
والخروج الى
بر الامان بهذا الوطن من خلال مؤسسات
واحده وحكومه موحده وانتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه حضوره الامم المتحده التي اعلنت
تاييده لخطه الرئاسيه اطفئ شيئا من الصبغه
الدوليه على الاتفاقات المبرمه
مدير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه